this may be a show about a bunch of
brilliant scientists but it doesn't take
a genius to recognize how disgusting
this one actor's habit is any fan of The
Big Bang Theory worth their salt knows
that the characters show up to do two
things take the stairs thanks to a
broken elevator and chew gum well maybe
they didn't really do that second thing
on screen but bear with us this will all
make sense in a minute
tell you a secret
throughout the series audience is
watched as the gang Sheldon Raj Leonard
Howard and Penny are forced to take the
stairs up and down in their apartment
building because their elevator goes
unfixed for years due to the way the set
is built there are spots the camera
doesn't quite reach and according to one
of the Stars it's good that some of the
prop walls remained out of sight as
Kunal Nair the actor who plays Raj
recently revealed one of his co-stars
had a pretty disgusting habit when it
came to those unseen spots on the stairs
in an interview with the Daily Express
Nair dished on how Leonard actor Johnny
Galecki seemed to regard the Wallace's
own personal trash can whenever they
were using the onset stairs
unsurprisingly Nayer said that those
stairs led to Nowhere which makes sense
what is surprising however is what stuck
to the walls that led to said nowhere as
the actor explained you run back up the
stairs that go nowhere and then you walk
back down as if it's a new floor down
there is nothing there's a wall there
where Johnny Galecki for 12 years would
stick his chewing gum on I'm not joking
there you have it folks if you're the
biggest Johnny Galecki fan in the entire
universe then who knows perhaps you can
buy his used chewing gum on the internet
because he's stuck it on a prop wall for
over a decade instead of just finding a
better way to dispose of it for anyone
else please enjoy the mental image of
dried up gum on the walls every time you
watch the characters in Big Bang Theory
traips up and down those iconic stairs
it's my problem not yours why golicky
was allowed to do this for that many
years and that many seasons is anyone's
guess but apparently if you're one of
the stars of the biggest sitcom in
recent history you're allowed to go hog
wild with your used gum on set it's a
good thing we know Johnny Galecki chewed
a ton of gum on the set of The Big Bang
Theory because his fake eating leaves a
lot to be desired whenever his character
has an on-screen meal it looks like the
lucky doesn't quite understand the
concept of put food in mouth chew and
then swallow that most adult humans have
mastered the actors across the board in
the Big Bang Theory with the exception
of Kaley Cuoco are pretty dismal at fake
eating but galecki's Leonard is
definitely indisputably the worst at it
It's Tricky acting and eating at the
same time because you have to time the
bite with the joke in every scene where
he has to interact with food he holds
his fork in a way that nobody has ever
held a fork before and just pokes
listlessly at his meal sure it's
understandable that he wouldn't want to
ingest every single calorie in front of
him in every single scene but there has
to be a better way around it then well
whatever Galecki is doing first show
that constantly places its characters
within Arm's Reach of food its actors
sure seem confused when they're supposed
to be eating
[Music]